a escuelas y comercios cerrados calles
desiertas una nueva jornada de huelga
general paralizó este lunes las
principales ciudades de haití los
manifestantes bloquearon las calles de
la capital puerto príncipe con piedras
árboles y neumáticos quemados para
protestar por la escasez generalizada de
combustible y la inseguridad que reina
en el país
si no podemos pagar nada estamos en la
miseria no podemos comer un galón de
gasolina cuesta 20 dólares hay que
denunciar estas cosas en la capital
haitiana muchas gasolineras permanecen
cerradas desde hace días por una grave
escasez de combustible en haití donde el
suministro de energía es aleatorio los
generadores diésel son los que producen
la electricidad y la escasez es tan
grave que varios hospitales del país
anunciaron esta semana que se están
quedando sin el combustible necesario
para seguir abiertos esa situación se
debe al bloqueo de las tres únicas
terminales petroleras del país desde
hace varias semanas por parte de bandas
armadas estas se han convertido en una
fuerza poderosa en haití la semana
pasada una de las bandas secuestró a 17
miembros de un grupo misionero con sede
en eeuu los actores armados también
atacan directamente a la población
haitiana y el gobierno liderado por el
primer ministro hay enojo parece tan
incapaz de enfrentarse a ellos como de
resolver el asesinato del presidente y
robben el mois hace dos meses